was the status of women when Muhammad
SAW seldom came to talk about what was
in the Dark Ages in Europe what was a
woman they were arguing in the church if
a woman comes from Satan or not if a
woman worth half a man or not if she has
a soul yeah that's another thing even
though the French I don't think they
would have worn the letter soccer match
the world champion is one for many of
the Muslims out there right and of his
life in the Exile he was he he converted
to Islam and actually some of those who
were his companions close to him index I
they testify that he used to pray and
[Music]
Salam alaikum greetings of peace guys
I'm here with dr. Fadi
Radhika blow and we are in Miami and we
had just before we started you were
telling us something bet you didn't know
this and we'll kick it off with this
Napoleon you heard of Napoleon right for
those that haven't heard of Napoleon
tell us who he who he was and you
actually said that he accepted Islam
alright tabali and bonaparte the French
conquer we all know about him we all
studied about him but we were never told
that toward the end of his life in the
Exile he was he he converted to Islam
and actually some of those who were his
companions close to him in the Exile
they testify that he used to pray and he
was to read Quran now this is
academically sound yes that you're an
academic that seems in his own biography
this is not from a Muslim or people can
go verify this on Google website now
that Napoleon Bonaparte Bonaparte
accepted Islam correct this is deep
correct in his own biography in his own
biography now what are some of the top I
just to mention please Napoleon
conquered Egypt and he claimed to
convert at that time and that was and he
worth a fillip and
yeah you were the turban but that all
was propaganda just to touch on the
emotions of the Muslims to passes on
agenda but later on told in the Exile
toward the end of his life he converted
for real he was French yeah now now this
is a coming from a place I mean he's
actually like a hero to many friends
right oh yeah big time
but but you see a lot of oppression
towards Muslims even though the French I
don't think they would have warned the
latter soccer match the world champion
it wasn't for many of the Muslims out
there right but you see them what it was
a banning hijab and minarets and all the
things over there French is the heart of
Christianity French always throughout
the history represents the heart of
Christianity so if you
if I mean French is under the threat of
turning into Muslims because of the
refugees because of the immigrations
because of that that's why there and
there's a lot of racism in the French
over the history you can't you can't
test for it a lot of orientalists you
know came from their Orientalist where
the people after the failure of the
Crusades in the Muslim world to convert
Muslims into leaving Islam at least and
then Christianity they fail to do that
so they said the best way then we need
to study this view so they start sending
orientalists called most assuredly who
posed as muslims and they learned
everything about muslims there in learnt
everything these people went into the
marketplaces in the masajid and the
circles of knowledge they learned
everything about muslims and they went
back to europe and they start
documenting that and giving
recommendation how we can conquer these
people and the things that happening in
the Muslim world over the last hundred
years is the fruit of all these three of
all this research because they realized
these Muslims are different than us
Christians it's not easy to uproot them
from their religion so how are we gonna
do it
that's why they you hear a lot of
sayings for example give me give me a
prostitute and a glass of wine and I can
do to the Ummah of Muhammad more than
cannons armies did you hear that you
don't know what you following desire use
me a woman give me a glass of wine
alcohol and using exploiting the woman
now right mm-hm and you and you advocate
like you know the rights of women but
you actually subjugating her in this way
denigrating her yeah but then you can
destroy yeah I said we can I'll do to
them more than what cannons and armies
can do wow those are those satanic traps
are the concerns our desires and their
this is where the Ummah Phyllis lands
our Deen is the right Dean our Quran is
the perfect book our prophet is the best
messenger so how can they attack us
throw them they can't so they said we
have to get to them through their jihad
and the desires humans and we're weak
you know do you find it ironic that you
see that everyone is trying to make
Islam as its as if its oppressive
towards humanity it's backwards but then
when you look at it you study Islam you
know you go back in history you know
when the Muslims were the super powers
you know the Christians Jews and
everyone what kind of rights did they
have living under the super power at
that time compared to now where Muslims
are like losing most of their rights
like under the Muslim super PAC yeah in
Superman I tell you what a Hebrew
professor in here a Jewish professor in
Hebrew Jewish Hebrew professor Jewish
professor in a heap on University in
Jerusalem in he writes he said that
there was never bear symbiosis between
Muslims and Jews then under Islamic and
there was Islamic Spain and if you look
if you read the the little history or
some of the history of Spain that's
where the Jews were best treated they
were scholars they were given the
opportunity to be merchants
businesspeople scholars philosophers and
their Islamic ruling yeah so when you're
when you are objective you have to
testify in the favor of this Deen and
this is by again by a Jewish occupant
you know I mean the Jews the Israelis in
falestine and Palestine are occupation
so he is praising Muslims
right saying that the Jews never had
better environment to excel than in a
Muslim Spain when Muslims were ruling
Spain then the Christians come the
Catholic comes to Spain what they do to
the Jews and to the Muslims they
slaughter them or feud oh if you don't
convert we kill you if you don't want to
be killed you live and if you look later
on in injure me who helped the Jews from
Hitler and the Nazis the Ottomans the
Ottomans sent their ships to save a lot
of the Jews from from Germany so this is
what Islam this is what Islam came where
was when they talked about women
what was the status of women when
Muhammad SAW seldom came to talk about
what was in the Dark Ages in Europe what
was a woman they were arguing in the
church if a woman comes from Satan or
not a woman worth half a man or not if
she has a soul okay that's another thing
yeah woman here in this country when did
they start voting
you know Islam so you say there's
development right there's progressive be
great but Islam started with privilege
started with it from the get-go from the
beginning Wow
yeah yeah America took how many years to
get to a point where a woman is we're
still talking about women wages right
not equal to men wages in America right
yeah so still in in the form of
evolution Islam from the beginning but
how is it so that all right if Islam
someone will say that if salaam gives
all these rights to the women how is the
common mantra nowadays that Islam
oppresses subjugate women how we got to
that when we're talking about all of
these rights that women have their two
issues here one misinformation and
nobody should deny that of what the
media can do right for example I give
you stats from 1800 until 1950 that's a
hundred of 150 years there were 70,000
books written against Islam Time
magazine
books yeah but I'm a true so you have
70,000 books written against Islam where
is the rebuff rebuttal of that
so and that's average over a book per
day and then after September that when
you have average three books written or
published every day against Islam so
what I'm saying is who's who's refuting
all that so now you that it the more you
keep hammering people with
misinformation they can I believe it at
one point so seventy thousand plus books
in a span of how many years now 150
years 150 years this was reporting to
check us on Time magazine did a
publication reporting this so this is
negative propaganda consonants one
that's only in publication in
publication for forget about Oracle's
forget about newspapers with Maggie I
get is the propaganda negative replies
misinformation you look half truth is a
lie if you have half a truth that's
basically a lecture but now come up into
the that's back in a day with a lot of
press but now today with Twitter or
Facebook media how much now if they did
a survey how much on top of that it just
lipo ganda so that's number one so
that's one second Muslims themselves are
giving bad name for is oh the way we
treat our women the way we treat
ourselves the way we treat humanity the
way we treat the world Muslims who are
now like the drunk driver behind the car
so the car is perfect that's Islam but
now the drunk driver comes be honest in
2010
I don't blame Muslims for the most of it
but Muslims have a lot of work to do
yeah they're failing on two parts one
following the way Islam should be and
second I mean we know Muslim
go out and start talking how making fun
of women how women my woman should be
serving me well this woman that could be
your mother could be your sister could
be your daughter
yeah if you accept that for this women
then you we can say okay you can accept
it so look at the seal of the process
look how he treated women right
look how how much he told us to kill the
process LM dying and two things is
ordering us to take care of Salah and
women prayer and the woman when he's
dying this is before his death but I'm
saying this yeah widely like holes hold
on to your prayer and treat women well
correct one is dying just yeah I mean
come on people are like thinking I mean
look at look at that that's deep if you
just reflect upon that you're on your
dying deathbed and you're saying hold on
to the connection of God the
and take care of women if he's an
oppressor of women why's he mention is
on his debit think about that that's
what so the Muslims need to do their
work in the way they carry themselves
right and in the way they practice their
Deen and the way they promote dirty
right our problem is someone attack us
by saying our euro you oppress women
so what we started with what we try to
do we become apologetic no we don't need
to our Deen is the only Deen that's the
respect women you know go read about in
Judaism in Judaism a few religious when
a woman in her menstruation she stays in
our the food is pushed to her from
underneath the door this is an example
you're giving come from another religion
Hinduism Hindu even Christianity so I
mean just look we we live in a Christian
country very much right what happened to
women
where's is his woman dignified you know
I Drive a lot to work maybe 5:00 in the
morning 6:00 in the morning I see women
maybe she's 70 80 years at the bus stop
maybe we're going to work that doesn't
happen to our women I wasn't so 70 80
years old she's now turning for herself
no one taking care better
so is this isn't this humiliation to
women that's one example you give a lot
of examples but my point is is we need
to stop being apologetic learn about
your Islam learn about your Deen and
then you will see how this Deen honored
women more than anything else right more
than anybody else no more modern no more
than or more than any other system any
other religion you can
so he said Dean Dean is this love the
way of life yeah the way of life learnin
learn how you profit are they come and
they tell you you're allowed to be
children right and there's a lien the
Quran say we don't well who's the best
one to live the Quran we as Muslims
demand we follow his footsteps in in
applying the Quran is the Prophet SAW
said he saw seldom did not hit a woman
in his whole entire life
pay attention at this one marker right
here Prophet Muhammad SAW never hit a
woman in his whole
tire life right maybe one time he pushed
I should just do make her to make her
think about what he's about but the
opponents of Islam that's a long hadith
it's interesting they will go and try to
use this to say look he did yeah but he
they're sitting with it's the context
behind that the context is he saw seldom
when he was sleeping next to a shovel be
Allah and during her night he decided to
get up and go to the graveyard to the
cemetery it appear in Medina and make
dua for the dead P yeah so the process M
was married to more than one so she's
being jealous she thought he's gonna go
to another one so she followed him so
it's imagine today today if you if you
take your phone and you decide someone
calls you and you leave your wife and
you go outside what happened when you go
back who did you talk to what how we
react it's not your business isn't it
and he did not push her for that reason
so when he came back of course she saw
him coming back she quickly went back
into her room and pretend she's sleeping
and and then she she brought it up he
said so you were the black thing that
was following me huh yeah and then he
pushed everything you think you're
because it's her night look at the
justice you thought that your husband or
the prophet of Allah will betray you in
your night like will cheat you and your
dad you know and that's why he pushes
that's not like come on like something
like a course of course but not the
point I could one time she is she has an
argument with him so I said this you
talk about The Messenger of Allah so
this is his wife regular girlfriend
mistress likes coming today his wife
this is the Messenger of Allah if you
tell the Messenger of Allah I don't
believe you
like as a regular person you're out of
the false official so one time she had
an argument with him so I said so who he
calls to to make concil between them
he's her father
positive brother Allah so so the process
the process I'm said who starts you want
me to start talking or even he's
arbitrary now a judge so she said you
you start it has the process you start
but you only say the truth
so what so so her father punch her net
right now her father he said how can you
say this to the messenger of oh yeah
what did the professor say London he
left he saw Salem sitting with his
companions and one of he was in the
house of Aisha and one of his wife sent
him plate of food so when I should seize
it takes it and break out of jealousy
would he laughed he said your mother got
jealous that's our Prophet SAW said so
don't come and tell me the Quran say you
can beat women okay how did the process
element nobody I she said he saw Selim
his whole aquas of Quran his morality or
his mannerism was of Quran
he was present representation of the
Quran yeah so judge me based on how he
saw seldom applied the foreman because
the Quran Allah in the Quran and send
with it the messenger of allah he's the
one who lived the quran so you see how
he lived and we apply this is a message
to those who attack us to those who
attack a Quran and this is a message to
Muslims who use the Quran to justify
their abuse because you are you here
some Muslim using that to justify you're
wrong you're wrong yeah yeah and this is
how it is so we covered the first one is
that deliberate lies and a malicious
attempt to kind of spread misinformation
and then a second is Muslims not being
well grounded in their Dean
misrepresenting it and then I often make
that example to others you know don't
judge the car by the drunk driver code
right so people Muslims not practicing
Islam correctly and now you take in that
as if it's you know because Islam is
pristine is perfect Muslims are not and
this is important the Prophet SAW salem
when he was coming back from one of the
battles and one of the head of the
hypocrites a lot nobody salute said when
we returned to medina the noble will
kick out the humiliated one referring to
him the no and the process area so when
when the news spread
one of those I have a marble hot thought
till the process item order me to go can
kill the hypocrite
so the prophesy Salem said what no we
don't want the people to say that
Muhammad is killing his companions so
look how he saw Salem cared about what
people would say you know if he missed
act or he acts in a way that they won't
get the full picture yeah
so that's responsibility upon every
Muslim of us how we act when I decide to
embark on a mission to to act in a
certain way the first thing that should
the first thought should be on my mind
is how am i representing a listener how
am i representing is Dean here when a
lot of Muslims this is one of the the
reasons why we are obligate as Muslims
to look like Muslims you find the Muslim
man obligated to grow beard you'll find
that Muslim one obligated to cover if
there is one reason for that is before
you act
people know you're Muslim so before you
act you ask yourself what they're gonna
say about listener hmm you know is that
to get that gives you a sense of
responsibility you know again I walk
into this place or I gonna say this word
or I gonna throw that joke or I gonna
check this one out
right what they're gonna say about
listening when Islam becomes a priority
then our victory welcome then as I when
Islam becomes more important for me not
what people gonna think about me what
people gonna think about my deal then we
get our conditions condition testimony
event of itself is you know many people
say like go talk to my wife why and many
we know that the fact is that Islam
according to the Guinness Book of World
Records is the fastest growing way of
life in the world and there's more women
accepting Islam that's like why are
these are intelligent women who won't
don't want to be just used and abused
for their body they want to be respected
for their intellect and Islam provides
all the evidence that's needed to show
this is the truth and they're coming to
us and whether we live in a world where
it only takes a phone call to call the
police if Muslims are as if you that
Muslim men or husbands
or as abusable as abusing as as they say
well we will all be behind bars yeah
it's so easy for over women to come it's
not it's not a fact it's not true it's
not even close to be true you know it's
go check the stats about domestic abuse
in the United States right I don't know
I don't remember but there is one on on
second bases there is one woman get
abused every few seconds in the United
States well we can we come and say oh
this is a Christian problem what
percentage of those are Muslims I bet
you it's very my note yeah so the idea
is oh this is old yeah it's becoming too
old and and this should give you an
impression that if this is the best they
can do to a circular smell yeah but but
this is interesting because people think
you know when you're beating your wife
there's no such a thing in Islam like
right right cross used to box today
right so right hook busted uppercut I
mean this is like you know this doesn't
exist when the process of them
represented that beating that they talk
about in the Quran he held the miswak in
his okay so that's my next question now
now someone says hold on I'll hold on
doctor shake you know the scholar in
Islam tell us look I'm opening you know
you know they're tuning in and not yet
Muslim there they're out there and they
they're they like the message of pure
monotheism they like this but they can't
get past this verse about chapter 4
verse 34 and in the translations is just
beat them lightly what are you talking
about
what is liking and what is the beating
and when does the being takes place
first of all we have to understand that
in Islam the man is in charge of the
family I don't need a good but before
you that please don't lose your place
isn't it so so much more complex because
when you translate words from the from a
different language into the English
doesn't that play a really big part
there does yeah does but but again we're
not going to go to the root of the
problem that
and start twisting it it's it's
straightforward say it but again what's
the meaning of that hitting right and
when does it happen so first we have to
understand there's that there is a
structure for the family in Islam yes
right
Elijah will put the responsibility over
the man to be in charge of the family
now this is not honor and this is not
privilege this is responsible big
responsibility huge responsible big
responsible I mean the man is the one
who needs to take care of the affairs of
the family he needs to spend on defense
one of the issues that you have in
America is the demanders and doesn't
want to pay for doesn't want to spend on
the family it becomes like a bomb it
becomes she has to take him to court to
spend on his children in Islam Allah
already dictated we call it just a bomb
not literal bomb like on the street
beggar he doesn't take care of his
business so so so there's a structure so
since he's the one in charge I mean we
accept the government being in charge of
us we accept that when we do something
wrong with the government gonna come and
beat us up or throw us in jail so in in
Islam or in the house it's like a small
government there's a structure which is
the husband is in charge right now this
husband to have that fulfilled or that
that entitlement right he needs to
really fulfill the conditions right and
Allah as though John makes it clear I
put you superior in the family as long
as you do 1 2 3 right so don't come and
tell me you fail in fulfilling your
obligations and you turn Allah put me in
charge right so when the man is
fulfilling his duties toward Allah and
his duties toward his family then he has
the right to be obeyed in the house now
when it comes to a woman who's not
appreciating who's not doing what she's
supposed to do as a mother who's not
doing what she's supposed to do as a
wife it was not fulfilling her duties
total - surgeon who's who's supposed to
be disciplining her it's her husband
we're not going to bring someone from
outside to discipline her but and how
Allah is I said advised reminded now how
long advise them for
it all depends right we just do to shift
a little bit when Allah talks about
advising our children to pray he said
what I said he said tell them to pray at
seven like order them to pray at seven
head them on it or discipline them at
ten so you have three years how many
salah in three years
how many forever about 5,000 right so
here allah awj it gives three years just
just tell them pray these kids pray pray
so when allah says the first step is you
advise her right how long it's you know
you know your wife you know is she
reacting you know is she responding and
you take you you be as patient as you
can with her adviser now why a woman
will not will not listen
why if I advise my listen you have to
pray I see you neglecting your prayers
why she doesn't have to why she should
not listen because she's a woman he's a
man who is he to give me orders and this
is a lot of it has to do with that
mentality that well I'm independent
person why is he giving me orders
because he's responsible about you and
he will be questioned about you we as
husbands will be questioned about our
wives who have shortcomings so I I want
to save myself at the end of the day and
I want to save you because I love you so
I'm just telling you my love dear honey
pray and I keep telling you I keep
telling you and you're not so I need to
take a second step what Allah says
second step turn your back to them in
depth in the same bit what people do to
them they leave the house he goes to the
bar he goes hang out with his buddies
Allah even go sleep on the couch that's
not in islam allah once reconsider allah
allah wants things to be resolved so he
said when you had desert her in bed
meaning you turn you back to her in the
same bed
don't go sleep in the other room right
and you try to do that and hopefully she
can't come back to her senses
when all that doesn't work you hate her
now the law says hair and end of the
story
right and lift it up to you you wanna
hit her with a sword you want her with
as you said uppercut
oh that is not only slams here's a rule
and he puts the details of it and the
products I said let me explain they
didn't he saw Salem pose a miswak and
miswak is like a like a pencil
you said you discipline it so that
that's like my god so we said to brush
or how like a stick your depth is also
on yes yeah so it's like so yeah my car
there's a Swedish Journal medical dental
journal yeah they did the whole research
about miswak and it was amazing right
I'm gonna ask you towards then the bond
so so so he put he holds and he said
this is what you're disciplined the
point is not to hurt the point is not to
leave marks honor the point is not to to
humiliate the point is to wake her up
it's like when I wake you up for salat
al-fajr you're gonna call that beating
you know and this is responsibility that
the problem we have is that the
structure of the family is broken down
so much we don't feel that we have
responsibilities toward each other my
job is to save my wife from the Hellfire
her job is to save me from the Hellfire
I will have no problem when I do
something harmful my wife to come and
push me and say what's wrong with you
right I have no problem and she should
not have problem and this is this is the
this is how Allah wants the family Allah
is the Prophet saws and praises a man
who wakes up in the middle of the night
and wakes is wanted to pray with him
yeah now someone will say yeah you're
disturbing that's interesting shake that
you mention that because nowadays are
many people have the I was thinking
about this what's your thoughts people
have you know consenting adults you know
they have these fetishes right now so
they'll end up beating the heck out of
each other for sexual pressures right
and nobody's calling the police on over
and they're leaving bruises and marks
and whatnot that's but but but this is
nothing of leaving
a mark or anything you know the face
touching the face but you know when
people go to extremes you know for
sexual pleasures you know they hang
companies out there and they're beating
each other and they're actually leaving
marks right and this is for pleasure
right I nobody thinks about it nobody
talks about right right or someone says
someone be like spank me honey and
they're doing you know this is all on me
okay Mary right she's just trying to hit
the point home all right my words
whenever it has to do we have to really
accept the fact that our religion is a
target so if it's I hear a lot of
Muslims trying to defend the list and
trying to make it look if we do not
acknowledge the fact that we are under
attack we will never understand what's
going on yeah
and nobody will understand that by being
on Facebook yeah if you don't dig deep
into the books and read the history how
the plot started in Europe and all that
you will never understand that the war
on this religion from the time of
inception our religion that the issue
they have with our religion our religion
is is once to change the system not any
other religion is interested in that
look at Hinduism look at Buddhism look
at dowsing Confucianism Judaism
Christian no just church and that's it
synagogue temple whatever Islam is is a
comprehensive religion is that's why
it's the final message and that's what
causes a threat if I'm Christian and I
want we should get rid of the of
government and there should mean be no
separation between state and church what
Christianity how can Christianity
governs doesn't have a system right we
need to get rid of few jury what
Christianity has an as an alternative
what any other religion has and as an
alternative for financial system look at
least slap it has everything that's why
it's a threat and always listen it's the
right of the of the others to fight for
their existence and they're finding us
because they see Islam is the only
threat
right we have to acknowledge that and we
have to accept that and this is a fact
this is not this is not delusional this
is not Muslims trying to to scapegoat
their problems this is a fact this is
historical fact and this is a fact that
is that is acknowledged by the non
Muslims before Muslims so if we don't
read now how do we react or that first
thing we need to hold tact our religion
our religion is perfect religion our
religion I asked some Muslims do you
believe that your religion is the only
right religion they say they say I'm not
sure what did they ever read the Quran
did these people these people involved
in that did they ever read the Quran did
you ever read the verbatim word of God
Almighty Allah of the Quran - look for
yourself
it's a question he's asking have him I
mean whoa when Allah is oh just sit in
Edina in Delilah's now the only way in
the sight of Allah is al-islam how can
you still have doubt that your religion
is the only true religion how can you
call yourself Muslims when when you say
I'm not sure your contradict and clearly
the Quran type now I'm not telling you
just because you're born Muslim you
should believe that it's a hundred
percent the right religion search for
yourself look for yourself and and you
will find the truth you will rely yeah
brother Eddie it's in there it's in
there every single day you you realize
things in the dienophile Islam that
makes you feel them makes you feel that
indeed this is the true religion I've
been everywhere I've been in everything
I've been involved in a lot of things
Islam non Islam halahala and and and
this is where I find my comfort and with
all due respect I'm not a guy who just
leads salon and know some Quran and give
a lecture and that's it I'm a successful
businessman I have my degrees I have I
went to some of the best universities in
America in the world yeah so I've been
there don't look at me as actually if
I'm crack you graduated from University
of Pennsylvania kind of Pennsylvania
which is an Ivy League Ivy League school
then
and you your and I'm doing my masters
now in business and Harvard at Harvard
okay so and I don't say this to show off
or anything but I want Muslims to
understand because this is we have sense
of inferiority you know
no no just because someone has a beer or
wear a goofy or lead Salah that doesn't
mean he's not intellectual doesn't mean
he doesn't know anything except Allah
and the Quran Dre and this is the
message I want to send I don't need to
go do my masters at Harvard you know but
I want I want it on my resume for you to
appreciate the fact that you can't
combine between two between the dunya
and that's beautiful you you can manage
to combine between the two and be
successful in both you know our Islam is
yeah sure if you look in the philosophy
of Europe right in the last two
centuries we hear about the European
philosophers reach a point where they
denied the importance of intellect when
it comes to faith right they said faith
is something you feel has nothing to do
with the mind has nothing to do with the
scientific method which is experimental
and proof you find Muslims who read this
and they want to apply that to listener
the Quran from cover to cover tells you
reflect think ponder right why the why
the European philosophers decided to
take that path because they know their
religion doesn't make sense they cannot
prove it intellectually you can't prove
Christianity intellectual no way right
so they knew that so they wanted to
defend their religion because they said
in their mind if we push people for
intellect they're gonna realize this is
a bogus religion the problem I have is
when Muslims try to apply the same thing
to Liz Lange
when Allah has those challenges from the
beginning challenges a humanity it
brings something like this you find
Muslims who say week we lift Islam and
this and that videos on YouTube and I
receive some brothers and sisters send
me these videos asking me like we're
confused you know
we left Islam because they fooled us
they told us that this book the Quran
nobody can't come up with a surah like
that right and they start calling all
these scholars of al-islam who-who are
rendered out of the faith because of
their ideologies from the past and oh we
can bring a thousand Quran like this
weekend this Quran can be imitated Quran
can be mimicked can be cut yeah so my
answer to them is come on like this
scholars they're coding right who
belongs to deviant groups Marta Silla
and Jamie and all these thing they said
Oh someone we can bring up thousand
columns like this do we have one from
1400 years ago until today like look how
easy you can refute an argument and you
you list me all these scholars
supposedly that they said well anybody
can write something like the Quran right
bring me one duty candy you know so so
so these are the Shuba and the doubtful
matters they try to spread all over to
fall in the hearts of the Muslim now
this is very simple to refute and when I
tell the I answered these brothers or
sisters about this they say wow that
makes it why did it make sense why you
were not ready to two to four it when it
came that's our problem is we are
reactive we are supposed to be proactive
as Muslims in all our affairs especially
in the in decides where we are being
attacked why I need to wait until
someone confronts me or attack me and
say you guys abused women right for me
to go and ask the shake or start reading
books or start learning what Islam says
about treating women for me to be able I
lost that opportunity to shut him down
yeah that's where we need Allah Azza WA
JAL encourages us in the Quran to learn
learn learn he tells the prompts I said
no that Layla halo before anything else
Philemon no Layla he doesn't know so
look this word now it's the first word
revealed is one echo echo are we read
learn grow they did a study in the Arab
world where the Quran is in their
language how much the Arab person reads
per year do you know how much per year
how much half a page
half a page a whole year cool yeah in
anything half a page on average a whole
year